connaissez-vous ces
parties de la frontière pas avec cette partie
pas encore il y a un épisode
d'hystérie à propos des barbares
[Musique]
j'ai des ordres à obéir
je parle de situations particulières
situations où je cherche la
vérité
puisque tout n'est pas  bien ici, je m'attends à ce que d'
autres mesures soient prises des
contrôles mènent des opérations pour
corriger la situation
que vous avez permis de développer
qu'est-ce qu'ils vous ont fait vous voulez que
je vous ramène à la
famille les barbares que vous
poursuivez c'est leur terre ils  tu n'en connais pas chaque
centimètre tu n'as pas
vraiment dit qu'il y aura une
grande guerre contre l'empire la
douleur est la vérité c'est comme ça que tu l'obtiens
tu n'as aucune idée à quel point ton
comportement est ennuyeux
[Musique]
tu es une torture obscène que
nous avons  lesdites procédures sont prêtes à partir
vous avez consulté
l'ennemi par trahison
sortez je veux que ces gens sortent d'ici
nous mettrons fin à ces problèmes
nous allons abattre l'ennemi
et ce sera la fin
vous